actually let me pull this story up and
I'll tell you about what's going on
right here uh let me let me jump to
timcast.com real quick
so and I'll explain where what I'm
talking about we have this story
right here take a look at this from
timcast.com feminine hygiene dispenser
vandalized in Oregon high school boys
restroom one parent told Tim cast news
putting feminine products in the boys
bathrooms is just asking for the types
of incidents to happen
so we see this photo
let me uh let me pull up the tweet and
our our journalistic team reached out to
the school and two parents got
confirmation got an email saying this
did happen I saw this photo and said
this is a fake photo I do not believe
this is a real photo it does not look
real the why is it grainy why is the
lighting so strange it looks like a bad
Photoshop and it's intentionally low res
so that you you can't see where the
seams are apparently it's real we like
we actually have I think uh two
different two different uh confirmations
that this did happen we're wondering
though if someone faked the photograph
to go along with the story that
originated from an email who took the
photo does it uh our team is working on
it right now actually because I asked
him I was like are we are we do we know
for sure there's just a teacher there
with like an iPhone 4. and so what we're
saying is we do have an email from the
school where they said this happened and
it's been happening quite a bit but I
don't know if I believe this photo is
real maybe it is maybe it isn't that is
the issue first I'll say this according
to the email that we got and speaking to
one of the parents it looks like high
school boys are ripping down feminine
hygiene products because they're putting
in the boys room for some reason so
that's kind of funny and based but um
you know kids shouldn't vandalize things
let's put it at that like the kids are
clearly protesting and this is their
right and uh but but I don't think it's
real like this Photograph doesn't seem
real to me at the very least I'm not
sure if it's real or fake and that's all
that matters come next year there will
be photos of Donald Trump and you're
going to be like Reasonable Doubt I have
no idea yeah there's enough doubt there
and there's no way to confirm it there's
no way to debunk it these AI Checker
checking things that I just don't know
that they can actually do it there was
uh one post I saw where a person said he
got accused of using chat GPT to write a
college essay and he was he was he was
posting about how he did not and the
teacher used a program that claimed a
paragraph Was AI generated and when he
said it's not they said we'll change it
then and no matter what he did it kept
claiming it was AI generated so what
he'll have to like write it right in
front of them so they can actually
physically see him write it yep but more
importantly
you're gonna see a video of trump and
you're gonna be elected that really
happen and the fact that you don't know
and have doubt means we won't be able to
have a conversation about a look I
wonder if it happened I have no idea
maybe what happens is Trump actually did
a bunch of bad stuff and he waits until
then he's got plausible he releases them
all at that time
you already had that story that one of
the krakensteins is on video saying he's
getting paid to troll basically and then
he said he came out and said that was a
clip from a skit that we were doing like
a like a like a bit and it's taken out
of context is it he could be lying yeah
he could be telling the truth
but I don't know why he would do a
hidden camera bit like that that's kind
of weird
like why would you do that the fact that
you can already say things like this and
people are going to believe it means
we've been in the post-truth era for a
long time I mean think about how long
ago it was when we had the very fine
people thing and and nobody just did any
research further nobody said hmm this
clip is cut at a very interesting place
they've had ways of doing this in the
media for a long long time it's just
going to be a lot easier for people to
fake it
there's gonna be pictures of Biden doing
weird stuff
but I mean like there's plenty of Super
Cuts on the internet if you want to see
Biden doing weird stuff but I mean like
it's gonna it's gonna get heavy that's
it's gonna get heavy that's the so
that's one of my worries is that the
government says look we can't people
can't discern between what is true and
what is not anymore so we can't have
elections or we can't you know like
that's something that I think is within
the cards like the government deciding
we can't have like people can't make the
distinction between what is real and
what isn't governments can't do it
anymore because AI generates things that
AI can't detect or whatever so that
means that we can't allow people to make
decisions for themselves and I don't
know that like I don't know that that
that is something that would happen but
I if I can conceive of the argument some
power hungry scumbag can definitely
conceive of the argument so I don't
again I don't know if that'll happen but
it's it's something that I wouldn't be
shocked in any way if there was some you
know somebody saying look we can't trust
our eyes and our ears so you got to let
the government take care of you because
you know they'll bring back that
disinformation governance board
yeah is as long as she debunks all the
misinformation and disinformation by
singing musicals that I'm okay with it
wait didn't they put Kamala Harris in
charge of the isn't she the aisar she's
yeah when she's not literally opening
the door for people to come into the
country the borders are and the AIS we
are screwed yeah hey eyes are that's
what that's I'd rather have the AI be in
charge yeah she knows something about
being on a flashlight don't laugh it
won't be quite as annoying when it
laughs at you yeah though I I will say
one of my favorite things recently is
that there's this guy who makes uh AI
videos of the last three presidents
singing together those are great uh it's
Biden Trump and Obama singing like rap
songs together it's fantastic so I mean
have you ever have you ever listened to
the Donald Trump sings yeah oh Maestro
zicos on YouTube oh he's fantastic his
cover Donald Trump singing Blinded By
The Blind it's fantastic yeah that's
really good let's uh let's let's pull
that and it's cut together with like
action well like it's not AI it's
literally he's taken from interview
pieces which means it must take
thousands of hours to make that here you
go I'll just play a second of it
[Music]
Maybe
I'm going through withdrawals
you don't even have to do too much it's
amazing
[Music]
he's amazing
half that guy's channel is just those
videos I know it's amazing they're good
so long to do but you mean to tell me
that that's not actually Donald Trump
singing the the one of him singing See
You Again by Wiz Khalifa is incredible
it's like an AI generated version of it
it's amazing
but I mean I think Donald Trump sings
Havana that's his most popular one
there's a Taylor Swift one that's also
really good
Havana
you mean this is not real
[Music]
in him
[Applause]
that's so good I think he watches these
at like two in the morning
[Music]
people Google themselves I bet you he
Googles himself
that's so good
there's something about his banners
brilliant I think his latest stuff is
like Joe Biden
Joe Biden sings in Chinese and he had uh
what is this uh Ella Baila Sola covered
by Trump see the thing is like during
The Last of Us presidential version his
videos are getting way more hits when
Trump was president and now he's got
like this Biden sings in Chinese 23 000
views
[Music]
this is like really hard to make too oh
yeah pulling up every clip of trump
saying a word such a pain yeah it's like
if people are like the reason it's not
popular now like it was a lot more funny
when I had money and I could afford to
put gas in my car it's not quite as
funny this time I can't afford food now
so uh so here's the problem though
Maestro zicos did all this work to make
these songs and we're about a year away
from you opening up your phone pressing
the voice to text and saying
render me a video of Donald Trump
singing blinding lights and then it will
just be like rendering and then boom and
it'll sound perfect I mean I've like I
admit to being in like I've been
watching a lot of like the like there's
a bunch of Kanye and Britney Spears AI
songs which is them performing songs
that they never sang and it's like at a
certain point we're just there now right
like you don't even have to actually
make the music
that weekend uh uh weekend and Drake
song is that what you're talking yeah
they they made an AI version of it and
it went viral yeah it's like music is
done yeah pretty much but I I suppose if
you own the rights
you're going to be good for a long time
because like Phil all you got to do is
tell it write me some new All That
Remains and then it will and you'll and
then you you have a render 100 different
songs then you go through them and say
these these five are good that's the new
album and then you're done in 10 minutes
I mean I I I assume that I would I'm
actually I'm not sure that I would
actually even bother going to track it
if if AI can do it yeah no you said yeah
well there's there was actually AI
rappers that companies were creating and
giving record deals I remember that FN
Mecca was like something like it was
just created by a company right and they
have uh AI activists now like AI social
media influencers that have actual
causes that they champion because
they're created by corporations but
you're just an avatar you you didn't
know that Brett yeah yeah yeah AOC not
even real not even real uh Greta tunberg
AI that's right yeah that's perfect
sense yeah I mean for all we know have
you ever seen them have you ever seen
him in real life Alex Stein I can tell
you he's not real yeah yeah that's how
that's how they did the the video of
Alex an AOC together because they're
both computer generated so when uh you
know when whenever we've had Alex on the
stage people don't realize it's it says
some kind of green in a green screen
suit I would believe that AOC is
actually created in the lab she's like
she's the perfect like antifis of
antithesis of uh Donald Trump we should
actually do that bit with uh with Alex
Stein it's like you see him on stage but
then we do a separate video where it's
just a guy in a green suit dancing and
rapping like it's not there's no Alex
sign he's he's AI generated yeah
Ian Israel though
Ian's not it's not real yeah his brain
may be attached to the computer but the
rest of them is attached to something
balloons thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at
8pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership help
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there